ce sera le plus gros télescope spatial
jamais construits dans le monde son
miroir réalisé en français est
actuellement en cours de test en
belgique et les premiers résultats sont
plus que prometteurs herschel c'est son
nom servira à percer les mystères de
l'univers invisible
patrick esther olivier palomino il y à
l'univers visible tels que nos yeux
peuvent le voir qui émet des lumières
directement perceptibles par notre
cerveau mais il est aussi un autre
univers mystérieux invisible uniquement
observable grâce au rayonnement
infrarouge ainsi une même région du ciel
peut s'avérer très différente selon
qu'elle est observée en lumière visible
ou dans l'infrarouge d'amour le tout est
depuis longtemps nous avons voulu faire
de l'astronomie infrarouge mais c'est
très difficile depuis la terre car la
vapeur d'eau de l'atmosphère forme un
filtre qui nous en empêche
la seule possibilité c'est de monter ces
télescope infrarouge sur 17 et vince
athée et voici le miroir révolutionnaire
du satellite européen destiné à percer
les secrets de l'univers infrarouge le
plus grand télescope spatial jamais
construits dans le monde
il porte le nom de williams et caroline
herschel deux pionniers qui inventèrent
ce type de télescope
ce satellite sera lancé par une
puissante ariane 5
c'est d'ailleurs le diamètre maximum de
cette fusée qui a limité la taille du
miroir
sa réalisation est l'oeuvre d'une petite
entreprise française de tarbes boostait
elle est la seule société au monde
possédant la technologie qui a permis
d'obtenir un miroir plus performant que
celui du célèbre télescope hubble
le miroir de beule mesure 2 mètres 40 de
diamètre et pèse une tonne et demie
celui des recherches atteint 3 mètres 50
pour un poids plume de 320 kg seulement
sa performance a été rendue possible par
l'utilisation d'un matériau fabuleux qui
est une céramique le carbure de silicium
qui allie des grandes propriétés
mécaniques a des propriétés thermiques
vraiment inégalée à présent placée en
orbite à plus d'un million de kilomètres
de la terre herschel commencera son
exploration de l'univers un vice
le dans 18 mois